[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
entrepreneur TB personality college bowl
co-host and he's Peyton and Eli's older
brother and the father of arch Manning
say hello to Cooper Manning our old
buddy look at you big time
remember remember when you worked with
us in New Orleans Manning on the street
now look at you
Dan I got to give you all the credit you
saw something in me that no one else saw
thank goodness Paulie came to me before
we went to that Super Bowl in New
Orleans he goes I got I got an idea he
goes you know Cooper is the funny
Manning and maybe we could just have him
on the street walking around creating
content and and you had these great you
know each day we had something that was
unscripted it was just funny and I uh I
really appreciated you taking a chance
there the next thing I know
now you're like a mogul
you're a you're a scout you're scouting
people in sixth grade next thing you
know they're getting drafted so that was
fun I remember it was three days it was
perfect weather running around the
French Quarter which is just I mean the
microphone and the camera the French
floor you're gonna run into some humor
and uh and we had a lot of laughs
probably a lot of stuff that didn't get
left on the editing room floor but we uh
I appreciate you taking a taking a stab
at me and uh I've had a lot of fun and
actually the couples several things I've
done lately are just all just you know
rooted in what we uh what we did those
three days at the Super Bowl Super Bowl
where you guys grew up but the Garden
District in New Orleans okay so the
proximity to the French Quarter it it
feels like the people who live in Vegas
who live outside the strip don't
necessarily go to the strip how often
would you and Eli and Peyton go to the
French Quarter
more often than you think it's really
only about I mean it's eight ten minutes
tops of a ride so it's not a big deal
tons of restaurants
um we're probably down there in high
school when we were not supposed to be
down there I think that you know you
could there are a couple bars there that
I think you know you have to be 12 I
think to get in so uh yeah you have an
idea if you're older than 18 it's
probably not a good idea for you to come
in here so um anything goes down there
and it's amazing yeah you have a
residential part of the world and the
next thing you know eight minutes later
you're uh you know anything goes so uh
fairly fairly often if I had a combine
with you Eli and Peyton
at let's say you're 18 years of age
who wins the combine
between you three
what are we talking about football
so for running that's also different
because at 18
um you know we're all playing different
positions but I would
uh I think Peyton Eli would agree that I
was probably
you know and again these are all
not fantastic you know Cutting Edge
combine kind of athletes I mean this is
a bunch of guys that can throw it and
you know who grew up and wound up those
guys wind up doing unbelievably so why
didn't you play quarterback
I was a quarterback and and then
um always growing up and then I was a
sophomore in high school and there was a
senior and a junior ahead of me and I
said I don't I don't want to watch so I
started playing receiver and then uh had
a you know had a good year made Allstate
and then Peyton was coming along I was
like this is gonna be fun and I just
kind of morphed into a receiver and so
Peyton was a sophomore and I was a
senior we had a great year together at
high school and uh caught a bunch of
balls he threw to me every time it was
very nice all the other parents of the
receivers hated me and uh and uh you
know
that's it how much of advice did you
give your son with all of this and and
trying to not be I mean you admire but
you got to be a father you got to be a
parent here sure uh that that kind of
fine line of you did a great job but let
you know I'm still your dad I got to
tell you right and wrong
right there's a balance the whole time
and I think it's funny I get a lot of
parents of recruits kind of asking me
questions how did you do this what'd you
think about that
um I really kind of took the the role of
just being kind of the concierge like
let's go look at these schools let's go
take a look dad I don't want to go I
want to just stay here my buddy that's
it I know but that sounds great but we
got to go see them otherwise you're not
going to be able to figure out what you
like and don't like so
um a little bit of a nag probably if
anything going let's take a look at this
stuff and then but he was he was a
little more mature I mean oh teenagers
are immature but he was a little more
mature in what he liked and what he
didn't like and I liked some stuff that
he didn't like and vice versa and uh and
it was his decision the whole way and I
was proud of the way he handled the
whole thing and he didn't want any
Limelight on him he's born to stay out
of the social media stuff he didn't
really want to draw any attention to
himself and he still kind of wired that
way like you know I want to do I want to
play play ball and enjoy it but I don't
want to be
um you know getting more more attention
than I than I deserve it's a lot of
pressure on him though Coop really a lot
and I go back to your father and I'm old
enough to remember there was a lot of
pressure on Arch he was on the covers of
uh Sports Illustrated back then uh at
Ole Miss and you know Peyton of course
had uh you know felt like there was a
lot of Spotlight on him maybe Eli not as
much and then Arch comes along he's
supposed to be he can't miss
I don't think that's fair to anybody I
think anytime you start you know
performing well here come the naysayers
and here come the pressure so it's just
part of the deal I think as long as you
know we're trying to keep it pretty
light hey look this is high school
football you're playing in enjoy it
enjoy your friends no need to add extra
pressure to it and I think that's why he
said look you know let's just hold off
from a lot of the media stuff and all
these early scholarship offers I thought
that was that's that's the worst idea
when you're a eighth grade and you're
throwing it pretty well or ninth grade
you have them success and all of a
sudden you start saying oh I'm glad I
got an offer from the University of
Florida my goodness gracious what a what
a bad idea to put even more pressure on
you so that's why really we try to
deflect everything as as long as you
could before you know it's just
inevitable that things start to get
started getting some attention but uh
undue pressure is uh you can kind of
control that
when did he get his first scholarship
offer
you know
entertain it it's like okay
you know you just it's silly because Dan
scholarship offers these days are not
real you know someone could come right
now and offer of sixth grader or a ninth
grader or an 11th grader offer you and
all that does for most people is give
them the the green light to announce on
social media I've got an offer from the
University of XYZ in hopes of other
universities seeing that and going hey
man we better offer them and so it can
you can and you can say anything you
want you can say I just got it all from
University of Utah Utah's never even
heard of you and Utah's not going to go
no he didn't it's just so it's it's a
lot of fluff out there it offers our
hotter you see people get 20 30 offers
and then all of a sudden it comes down
to you know uh I want to make a
commitment they're like
you know it's more like hey do you want
to go to dinner sometime maybe in the
next five years
sure
so it's it's a little fluffy the Capital
One college bowl finale is Friday night
with back-to-back episodes at eight
Eastern on NBC tune into the
championship episodes BYU Columbia
Georgia Penn State go head to head who's
tougher to work with Eli or Peyton
Peyton
it's just demanding you know and but
it's rewarding Eli's so easy it's you
know you don't know if you're screwed up
or you killed it you pretty much know
where you stand
and so
um I will say that week we filmed this
for a week together and over in Atlanta
and uh we laughed a lot we had a good
time and we're together a lot I'm sure
he's way ready to get the heck away from
me after a week of uh seven to seven
days but uh we it was Peyton's really
good he Demands a lot of himself and
therefore
um you know we're rehearsing things and
I screw up and like I gotta do it again
you can see him over there like
you're killing me you're literally
killing me so
um you kind of you kind of breathe out
get your A game ready because b game is
unacceptable but he probably goes in and
acts now you know what his teammates
feel like felt like you know you're in
the Huddle you're at the line of
scrimmage and you screw up
I I I think people get you know they
don't uh you know they don't stay up
that extra 30 minutes and watch a little
Matlock they go to bed and get the rest
they don't you know have an extra beer
and say oh I'll be fine tomorrow uh-uh
you better be on your game because uh
and he'll call you out on it that's the
thing Peyton does not care about you
know telling you the truth and he's not
wrong he's but he's uh he's pretty uh
he's pretty Kurt are you still a Saints
fan
yes I am
you know it's funny it's a crazy way to
grow up a Saints fan go to all the games
in high school obviously growing up
going with my dad but even my dad did
the games he did the the uh the color on
the radio so we would go to the games
and get a ride home with him go down the
locker room knew everybody and then all
of a sudden you have a brother that
plays for another team and you got to go
whoa wait I got a pivot here and so you
become a Colts fan you literally do you
kind of put the Saints in your hip
pocket and then you get a Giants and
then they could they get even you know
put in another pocket and so you're
rooting for other teams and then you
gotta then all of a sudden you gotta
come back to them and sometimes you got
to play them and it's it's awkward as
heck to have a a team and all of a
sudden you have other teams you know
because of blood that become way more
important to you than your uh in your
hometown team so I'm uh I'm I'm I'm
flirting back with uh get back in in bed
with the Saints which is uh which is
good when did you know your dad was
famous
uh pretty early on you know like
kindergarten probably when you go and
people start you know go places and
people want to come over and talk to
them at a lunch spot or you just you
know I remember when uh he would come to
recess every now and then when we were
in kindergarten or Pre-K and come and
play permanent quarterback at recess and
you know everybody kind of when when a
four-year-old kind of knows your dad's a
big deal you kind of go hang on here
something something's going on but he
did wear his full uniform which I
thought was a little tacky on this you
know yeah yeah I thought the helmet
might be a little over the top
the roof hour and so uh that was always
fun though but it was always good I mean
it was you know it wasn't like you know
he was a you know mob boss or something
everybody wanted a piece of it you know
autograph we wanted to hang out so it
was uh it was fun but I didn't know if
they blamed you or made fun of your dad
because the Saints weren't good when he
was playing for them never really felt
that I don't think you know I think uh
no it was definitely the other way it
was always very uh uh proud to have him
around and you know I thought it was
always a A plus definitely a a neat way
to grow up is having your dad play play
football for the hometown team man how
could you guys not be so competitive
with one another like like you're the
older brother but can you can you
discipline Peyton is your younger
brother and Eli like could you yell at
him and you know did
we fought a lot yes it was bad like
physically like battled yeah I think my
dad really had concerns about us ever
being able to complete a you know a game
of one-on-one Hoops in the backyard
without blood and fighting and crying
and quitting and just absolute you know
it's like you hear my mom would hear
some she'd be in the kitchen like Archie
get out there you know you could hear
like bedlow and so that lasted a while
it was really more Peyton us too because
Eli is five years younger than than
Peyton is and seven than me and so you
didn't it just wasn't as you don't you
know beat up a guy five years younger
but the guy two years is good because
Peyton was you know that two-year Gap is
pretty pretty big when you're eight and
six and you're ten and eight it's enough
to wear
he can see that he could maybe win one
but he's probably not going to just
because of age and that drove him crazy
and then I cannot my ego could not
handle getting beat by a nine-year-old
when I'm 11. so drove me crazy so then
it's just
it just never it just never ended very
well
well I'm happy for you the entrepreneur
TV personality college bowl co-host
Cooper Manning great to talk to you and
uh hopefully we'll cross paths in person
great to see you Dan thanks for having
me tell the boys I said hello I will
that's Cooper Manning boys Cooper says
hello to you guys hi Cooper